Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic,
l'antimatière.
L'univers est composé de particules élémentaires.
Ces particules existent sous différents types,
comme les électrons, les quark up, ou encore
les photons.
Chaque type de particule est caractérisé
par différentes valeurs.
Sa masse, son spin, et des nombres quantiques.
Les nombres quantiques sont des propriétés
des particules,
comme par exemple la charge électrique.
Il existe pour chaque type de particule, un
autre type de particule, avec la même masse,
le même spin, mais une charge électrique
et des nombres quantiques opposés.
Ainsi il existe des anti-électrons qu'on
appelle positons, de charge positive alors
que les électrons sont négatifs, il existe
des antiquark up, de charge -2/3, ou encore
des anti-photons.
Cependant, comme les photons
ont une charge valant 0,
l'anti-photon a également une charge valant 0.
Ainsi on dit que le photon est sa propre antiparticule.
Comme l'antimatière se comporte exactement
de la même façon que la matière ordinaire,
on pourrait par exemple composer des anti-atomes, et ainsi toutes sortes d'anti-objets.
Cependant, lorsqu'une particule et son antiparticule
entrent en collision, elle s’annihilent,
en libérant une énergie très importante,
qui se traduit le plus souvent en photons lumineux.
Ainsi des objets d'antimatière ne pourrait
pas coexister avec des objets de matière,
car les deux s'annihileraient tout de suite.
Dans notre monde, qui est composé de matière,
les antiparticules sont donc très rares car
elles disparaissent quasi-instantanément.
Mais il en existe.
Des antiparticules peuvent par exemple être
créées lorsqu'un rayonnement cosmique très
énergétique, en provenance par exemple des
explosions de supernovae, entre en collision
avec des nuages de gaz, ou encore avec les
particules de l'atmosphère terrestre.
Se pose alors la question de savoir pourquoi
notre monde est fait de matière, et non d'antimatière,
si les deux sont indiscernables.
Cela impliquerait qu'au moment du Big Bang,
à la naissance de l'univers, auraient été
produites un peu plus de particules que d'antiparticules.
Cette asymétrie entre la quantité de matière
et celle d'antimatière, aurait entraîné
la disparition de l'antimatière dans notre
univers.
Cependant le problème de l'asymétrie baryonique
est encore une énigme à résoudre, et il
existe de nombreuses hypothèses.
Par exemple, l'univers aurait pu se scinder
en deux mondes: un monde de matière, le
nôtre, et un monde d'antimatière, avec peut-être
des anti-atomes, et des anti-étoiles.